[Music]
[Music] Good morning, sir.
We're
interviewing you today for a
website called Serview. We'd
like to get your opinion on the
financial crisis, the development of finance,
perhaps your relevant opinion,
your expertise, maybe some experience in the
field. Jean-Manuel, Jean-Manuel Ros, please
introduce yourself. Good morning. I worked
for 30 years in
finance as a trader and then as an
advisor on various
investment strategies. For the past three years, I've
left finance
to dedicate myself to a search engine
called "Quant." I also wrote a
book on finance called "Le Fric
J" (1989) where I explained why
I was going to stop
trading. Good morning, good morning again. Yes, indeed.
Could you
introduce yourself? Well, I worked in
finance for 35 years, in
banking and investment banking, and currently
I work for three
companies, one of which was created 15 years ago.
years and which does
intermediation and is called
Tradition, another which is in Lausanne
and London,
another which
finances infrastructure and has
become a world leader, and finally a
real estate company that
I helped create 20 years ago with a
loan of $200,000 and which
today is worth $200 million thanks to
some judicious investments.
You forgot a card up your
sleeve, you are also an important member of
the Trilateral Commission. Yes, the
Trilateral Commission
brings together lots of people and so I am one
of them. Okay, I'm going to
ask you a first question to get to the
heart of the matter. We recently saw
the ceiling of the American debt reach
its limit. We see the ceiling of the
American debt reach its limit every 6 months,
but American growth
seems to be picking up again. Can you
explain to us a little bit this
difference in perception between a country
that every 6 months has to ask for
its debt ceiling to be raised and
growth that looks or seems to be picking up again?
It's starting up again for a
reason that depends neither on the Americans
nor on us; it's a cycle, you know, and
economic cycles last between 4 and 8 or 9 years.
We are very likely entering a
more
favorable cycle after there has been a
destruction of
wealth so that
old methods and
somewhat outdated industries in
the United States and elsewhere can be renewed.
And right now, we are entering a
different cycle. So, the American debt is
increasing, and it's
increasing in a way that doesn't
seem excessive to me, given the 320
million inhabitants and the 24 trillion
dollars that
characterize... well,
Jean-Manuel Roson, what
can you tell us a little about
your past as a trader? What did
you see in the
trading rooms? What
was your
role? First, a word about the
American debt. When I was in the United States,
I remember the first time
the markets were worried about the
American debt, in my experience, I
think it was in...  Since 1981, the
American debt has always been renewed, and
as Mr. de Carois says, it is
growing, but it is growing less rapidly than
the American economy, especially right now.
And if the American economy is
growing so fast right now, it's because there is, of
course, a new cycle.
But this cycle is characterized by two
things, in my opinion, which are major and
which explain why tomorrow's growth and
wealth will solve
yesterday's problems—something many
analysts refuse to see. And so
people continue, I would say, like fools,
to be negative about the market
that has been rising for five years. Well, it's
because tomorrow's wealth will solve
today's and yesterday's problems. Why?
Because there are a billion people
who are going to reach the
middle class, and they will do so with
mastery of information technology and
knowledge that is unprecedented in
the history of humanity. So that's
the force that's coming, and for five years
the markets have been rising, and for five years the
same analysts have been telling you...  It's
appalling, it's going very badly, it's going to be a disaster.
Reading
yesterday's paper, we don't care, what matters is
tomorrow's paper. That's what
I wanted to tell you on this subject. I have,
I'm going to ask you a
question about trading floors, about the
profession of trader. Do
traders pay any attention to the
fundamentals of the economy, or do they
simply do technical analysis? Is that how one becomes a
trader? How do you place your bets, for
example, on oil? Do
you have someone in
the trading rooms who monitors
oil products or
new technologies? Do
you have an
analyst's brief every morning that informs you
about the reality of the fundamentals of
the economy? Well, I need to give
a rather long answer because it's
a complex question. First of all, there are
many people who call themselves
traders and who are only brokers.
The difference
between brokers and traders is that a trader is
someone who makes a decision,
commits capital to the markets,
and a
broker is someone who calls a trader
to suggest a transaction.
Obviously, these are different levels of
expertise. For each, you need
different skills and talents. To be a broker, you have to
be a good salesperson, and if you
give bad ideas, it's annoying in the
short term, but you can always
find another trader. When you
ruin one, the bank will hire another. So,
brokers
really need to be good salespeople
rather than good analysts. There are
analysts in brokerage firms
and among traders. The modern world has
created many, many specialties, which is why it's
difficult to give
you a quick answer.
In one of these specialties, there are people who
do macroeconomic trading based
on analysis, where you need a
global overview of what's happening in the
world. You're the one who brings
the information back to you. When  I was a trader,
obviously. I never read the
newspaper and I never listened to anyone. What
interested me was the
prices, the speed at which they
formed, how I saw them
moving, and since I mainly traded
options, the
price differences between one option and another
allowed me to make decisions. So it was
a mix in my day—a very
long time ago—of
extremely rapid macroeconomic analysis and
investment decisions based on
the relative prices of different
instruments, which were sometimes
overpriced or underpriced. That has
evolved a lot; there are many
things now,
Hervé. What's important today is
that the methods have evolved, the
complexity of the
mathematical models has increased and requires
increasingly skilled people. And the
real question is
who should take positions. And
for me, banking institutions shouldn't
take
proprietary positions of any kind because
they are increasingly gambling with
large sums that can jeopardize
the deposits for which they are
responsible. You talk about leverage, leverage,
and then...
What is the role of a bank? The
role of a bank is to take
money from clients and make it available to
other clients
who want to create
economic growth. The wealth of wealth... well,
I don't think that, in a
very precise way, when a
bank plays the market, sometimes earning
hundreds of millions by playing the
market, it contributes to
economic development. Jean-Manuel, could you
explain to me a little bit the
philosophy of trading floors, the
philosophy of the people who
work in trading floors?
Is the primary goal of a
trading floor to take money,
make money, and lend
money again, or is it to take money
and take
money? There are many things, and
in a trading floor, in
trading floors, there are certainly many
teams with many
different roles. I would just like to take a
little step back. I'm going to take a step back.
I'll give you
a generic answer... no, not
generic,
theoretically precise, and my  The experience has
been that the main role of all the
players has tried to create
complexity that allows them to
take money directly from
their clients' pockets by selling them
things they didn't understand at inflated
prices. Is that
the essence of the
complexity of the business over the last 30 years? It's not just that,
I don't want people to
think that's all there is, but there's a
lot of it, and that's why
banks have transformed into
gigantic product-selling machines. On
one side, there's a trader
somewhere who creates a very
complex product and makes it as expensive as
possible, and then there's a team—even
if the team name says, "
Managing Director and Partner
for the Middle East"—the guy
doing that is still someone who,
deep down, doesn't understand anything about product pricing, how it's
structured, how it's made
available to the
client, and what it earns when
sold to the bank.  What he knows
is that he has a whole bunch of clients
to whom he needs to sell as much as possible,
so that's what happened.
Obviously, that wasn't the original goal.
The original goal would be to ensure
that companies that need
money and the positive players in
the economy who know how to raise
capital, create jobs, and generate
wealth can always have
that sum available to them. Unfortunately,
in French banks today,
we are very far from that. Hervé, I'm going to
ask you a question to follow up a bit
on current events. We saw not too
long ago the
LIBOR scandal, the manipulation of
certain interbank rates by
traders and large banks.
I would like to have your opinion, you
experienced man: is this
logical? Is it a
common practice? Are governments
sometimes aware of it? What do
you think about a
trader setting a price and passing
information via the intranet to his fellow traders?
Fixing prices in a
somewhat
obscure way is a common practice.
It's a common practice because
bank management hasn't
implemented David Rockefeller's formula
for Chase, which allowed Chase,
during the 40 years I was with them,
to avoid difficulties related to
questionable practices. What was
this rule? If there's any doubt, there's no
doubt. That is to say, whenever a
trader, whenever a manager,
encountered and made
decisions contrary to the
basic ethics of the firm, they were dismissed.
Well, this means
that all these practices—we must assume that
they are known to department heads, to
senior management—and that they are tolerated
because of
the
significant profits that these practices
generate, both for the bank and for the
team members. Jeanu, I'd like to
say something
specific about this: the
precise mechanism of the system's perversion in the
cases where it has been perverted, because no
reference has been made to  Your book, because it wasn't
corrupted all the time and
everywhere, but the precise mechanism is as
follows, and I'm dating it because I
saw it from the late 80s. At a certain point
in finance, finance
belonged primarily to these
owners. At Goldman Sacks,
at Smiths, the owners were
the managing partners, and they were
liable with their assets. So
when there was doubt, there was no
doubt because the risk was
theirs. At a certain point, these firms became
corporations.
The shareholder on the stock exchange was the one who
bore the risk, and the
department heads, the directors—that is to say, the
bosses—realized something wonderful:
if they gave a lot of
bonuses to a lot of people,
they could claim one for themselves, and so could the boss's
boss, and the boss's boss.
And ultimately, it became
exclusively, yes, a race for
bonuses, and that's what opened the
door to excesses. There weren't only
excesses, but there were many
excesses, and the second  The reason is that
internal controls
failed considerably. When I take
a bank where I had
general management responsibilities, it took us
four years—and I was somewhat
familiar with the market since
I was a trader at the beginning of my career—
to implement in-
depth controls on all these
transactions. The
auditors took years to attract
former traders to their ranks to be
able to investigate salary issues.
It's about
salary, about comfort.
How do you bring two
traders into a team of ten
controllers? It's not easy to manage, you know.
And so on. So everyone was
behind, and everyone was behind
because the sums at stake
for the companies were very
significant, the gains for individuals
even more so. And so there was
widespread collusion. Let's take current events as an example,
the fines that
some large banks have received
from governments and
market regulators. To make
a comparison, a large bank...  Who
paid their fine? To draw a parallel,
it's the equivalent of a €25 fine
for someone earning €50,000,
which is a pittance. Hervé, I'd like to
follow up on your point: do
states understand anything? Doesn't
the complexity of
market mechanisms,
financial mechanisms, trading floor mechanisms, and
the complexity of traders
confuse regulators and
governments? The word "states" is a
vague term. There are
specialized departments within the treasury. Okay, let's
take the example of the Ministry of Finance (
Bercy). Are the civil servants at
Bercy competent and
courageous enough to demand accountability? They do,
they've improved their teams, but they can't, any
more than
external authorities, verify the intricacies
and details of the operations that are
carried out. And it happens that
a bank I know very well
lost $200 million, which was
recorded a month after
the arrival of the auditors, the
statutory auditors, and the controllers.
In other words, these operations are
extraordinarily complex,
and the State, the auditors, the
internal control bodies, are rarely, were rarely,
equipped with the necessary personnel.
They are much more so today.
Jean-Manuel
Unot, I think there are always, and will continue to be,
specific problems
where control is difficult, control
is somewhat slow, the people doing the
control don't have all the power, all
the access, and ultimately, they can
always be a little behind.
However, I think that
systemically, if we take the entire
financial system, let's take dates like 2007,
when the financial system was riddled with
substandard and extremely
dangerous things that were about to explode, and 2013 or
2014, today I think that
overall, things are much, much,
much better, and I am still
very positive about the
global economy, about growth, and about the
markets. I certainly think a crisis
is possible, but I don't believe it will come
from this same kind of problem;
it will come from... according to you, we would
need the newspaper.  The day after tomorrow, and I don't have it, I don't know,
I can't
say. China, maybe,
yes, generally it always comes from a
surprising place, so it's difficult
to say. I can't
answer you today. We don't
really see, and it's very strange when you're
French, we're going to shock people,
today we only see
pink or red or blue at the origin. That is to say, we don't see
danger, we see a world that's going faster and faster, better and better,
where there are more and more
opportunities, more and more knowledge and
talent, more and more
solutions, and more and more capital. That's it
for projects. That is to say, what's
lacking right now are
projects because there are roughly thirty
trillion dollars
invested in monetary assets, in
loans to states, and so on. I mean,
the money is there to, to
simplify a little, this capital
is based on a promise.  Regarding future work,
if I summarize very simply,
they are based on enormous profits
made by countries that sell
raw materials or are very
efficient, like Japan, Germany,
and China. So, these are reserves
between the jobs these countries create and
the surpluses they have, and they are
growing.
Jean-Manuel, what do
you
think about raw materials overall? Will their price rise
or continue to rise? Will the price
of raw materials continue to
rise? Yes, I think so.
Many have come down, it's
calmed down, and so on. But since, as
I just said, there are a
billion people with
increasing consumption, they have to
consume something, and so this
will push the price of everything upwards: stocks, real estate
for the
wealthiest, wares and bastards,
contemporary art, and
raw materials that will have to be consumed. But what's
complex
in this reasoning is that,
obviously, we can complain about it for
those  They don't have access to that world
because it makes everything more expensive, but
we can't complain about the
rest of the economy because this
price increase is also enriching,
especially for the producers of these
raw materials in
emerging countries. I'm going to focus on
this option of my
growing market, which is going to
explode in both
emerging and developed countries.
Look at the growth in the United States. A
word perhaps on speculation on
raw materials. Speaking
of which, it really, really, really needs to be curbed—
and it's very, very
easy to do. I
created, I'm talking about myself, in 2000 I created
an NGO called LIFE Organization,
which suggests—perhaps
you'll be very opposed to this—that there be
innovative financing in the world, a tax on
transactions in commodity derivatives markets,
especially futures and
options, for
a simple reason: look, it's very,
very easy, we all have the  With modern methods, there are
clearing houses, so every time a
future on an agricultural futures market where
an option is traded, we know exactly who
bought it and...  And we can know if
it's a speculator acting on behalf of an
individual, a private bank acting on behalf
of an
investment fund, or a farmer who
needs it to manage their position. There's no
problem taking 1% on
the round trip from speculators who
use this market solely to
try to make money and
take nothing from producers. So,
tax these markets in this way—a
small marginal tax—and give that
money either to states to
reduce their debt or to development for a whole
host of things that are very
easy to do with
international agencies, for disease relief, for
education in the developing world. It's
something that is absolutely
essential and necessary, and the only
reason we don't do it is
because there's a
banking lobby that scares the whole world
and says the world will collapse if we don't do it.
But that's really nonsense in
my opinion. If we do it, in
my opinion, it's really just a drop in the ocean.
False, that's a lie. That's right, that's
right. We must
sanction speculation in one way or another
and allow
hedging operations for producers.
The difficulty lies in the
implementation, because we need
the agreement of 30 or 40 countries. If we
implement this throughout Europe and then
find
30 banks doing this on a remote island in
Oceania, or in the Caribbean, if you
prefer, then for that, we need
the agreement of the 30 main countries
in the world, starting with the United States.
But it's fundamental to
do this, and it will
slowly penetrate the American,
European, and Asian elites. I think that
in the next 10 to 15 years, we will have made
progress. Speaking of the elites, just a
word, just a little word. So, please,
sir, you're right, it's complicated to
convince the elites.
I've been working in the world of
finance for 32 years, I have friends, so since then,
some  They have large
hedge funds in the United States. I called
two of the biggest hedge funds
to tell them to support me on this
micro-tax on
derivatives markets. That was two years ago. I'm
still trying to get them on the phone; they think I'm
crazy. They want it, they don't want it,
they're wrong, and one day they'll
understand. Yes, they'll understand
when the time comes to bust, that's for
sure. Or Hervé, you talk about elites.
When you use the concept of "
elite," it's the 1%, the famous 1%. What does that
mean? What does "
elite" mean to you? For
me, the elite is first and foremost responsible people, right?
So they have to have
responsibilities, and you don't have
responsibility if you don't have power, right? So,
power and
responsibility, combining the two,
you arrive at a small group
of men, a few thousand
in the world, who can make
decisions. These are the people you have to
convince, and where to start? With the
banks.  Central banks, right? Because a bank isn't going to
go against what
a central bank tells it to.
If it does, a bank can
always have a liquidity crisis or some other kind of
crisis;
it needs the central bank. So, out of maybe
10,000 people
making decisions, 20
count: the top 20
central banks in the world. If together
they decide on what has just been
proposed, and which I fully support—that is,
a tax on pure
speculation, which isn't complex to
implement—and if they put it in place and applied it,
we would have taken a considerable step forward.
So, what to do with this
money? Indeed, that's a very good
question. But let's collect it first, and then
we'll find
useful applications. I'd like to
come back to the
Trilateral Commission and this famous complex, this
famous concept of an elite.
Could you elaborate a little,
explain what the
Trilateral Commission is, how decisions are made?  Is there
a steering committee? Is it a bit
like the people who
run the central bank? Are they
influential people? I'm
listening. Try to demystify it for us, or
go into detail about the Trilateral
Commission. The idea of ​​the
Trilateral Commission came from David Rockefeller
35 years ago. He
gathered a few dozen Europeans,
Americans, and Japanese, saying, "
Look, we have
common problems, for
example, relations with China, for
example, relations with what was then
the USSR.
Let's try to have common positions
that are in the general interest." Does
the Trilateral Commission exert
pressure, for
example, to launch a tax on
speculation?
It could? Why doesn't it?
Because
the word "pressure" bothers me, especially when
you have 150 Europeans, 120
Americans, 150 Asians, and it took us
10 years to get Chinese members
in our group who listened to the
reasons why we should
continue to liberalize trade and
control it much more vigorously.  The
banking system avoids
speculation, being more
generous both within countries and
abroad, and globally towards
the poorest. This creates a
movement,
and our role is not to make
decisions, but to set
guidelines adopted by leaders from
all sides. We always have
political leaders from one
party and from the opposition,
we have people from
unions and from business, and
together we try to develop
solutions to the problems of capital migration.
We try to work together,
and the mere fact of working together for
three days a few years in a row changes
our mentality. Hervé, one
last little question to finish on
the organization:
when the
Trilateral Commission has access to
very important people, you told us about
unions, perhaps a little bit of journalism, right? Yes,
absolutely. From an
external point of view, could it be
perceived by the population as an
unhealthy collusion that unions find themselves
with business leaders
and journalists?  From a table,
to simplify things, they shake hands
or kiss each other on the cheek or discuss
slightly more complex subjects. Don't
you think there's a bit of a
conflict of interest? And I'll give you
an example: powerful people—I do
n't like the word "caste," but
powerful people from a certain elite. Like
in any population sample, there are
often delinquents or people
who aren't acting in good faith. Don't
you think that these people, this
tiny percentage within this tiny percentage, have a very
significant impact on the environment? And how do
you go about, let's say, getting rid of these "
little ducks" or "bad apples"? It's
very simple: the David Rockefeller rule.
If there's any doubt about the integrity of anyone in
the
Trilateral Commission group, they're
immediately removed. It's happened, it's happened.
Absolutely not, no, no, not today, never. No, no, no, no, no, no,
Jean-Manuel, you're talking, yes, I
was saying that I wanted to react and  To say that once again,
when the
Trilateral Commission meets and makes
suggestions, there's
often a reverse lobbying effort to prevent
things from happening, particularly,
for example, regarding micro-
taxes on financial markets.
This lobbying is, once again, driven by
the desire for
bonuses. A whole bunch of people are
thinking, "Oh dear, if we
do this, I won't be able to continue
earning so much money doing what I
want. We absolutely have to stop."
And this is quite powerful because there are
many people who want
bonuses. And I must say, the
annoying thing is that it seems to me that in this
world, and in
other worlds, like that of
very large corporations, there are a lot of
people who believe they
deserve the very high salaries they receive. And that's wrong,
absolutely wrong.
Because in reality, if you try to think about
where the value creation lies, is it
in...  The activity of the individual, where
we know what the
organization and society provide to that
individual to be able to carry out their activity,
and you take, for example, traders,
to be a trader, that is to say, to be able to
manufacture a product that at the end
of the chain will be sold at a very high price to a
client, somewhere, requires lines
of credit, offices, credibility,
and so on, a whole monstrous system
that has to be managed, and the guy who is there, we
can take him, we can fire him, we can
put another one in, he is quite
replaceable, and so in reality the value
belongs 98% to the organization and
2% to the individual, and a group
of colluding individuals try to make us
believe that it is the opposite, that it is
50/50, and as long as this continues, we
will fail, but it is false, it is
just false, here are solutions,
bring us solutions, there are some, there is
one, it is not to do what Charles
Morgan did, Charles Morgan lost 9
billion last year and  Morgan, which
is a bank—yes, yes, yes, a very
large bank, the world's largest bank—
and its CEO
received a $23 million bonus in 2013. $23
million, or $23 billion? No, $23 million in
bonuses is colossal for someone
who lost $9
billion. So what I'm trying to
say is, what can be done? We need
responsible boards of directors, and
the central bank should verify that
executive compensation standards are
consistent and fair. Because where there is
injustice, it impacts the integrity at
every level of an organization. We have
n't talked about sanctions, uh, well, we
should have fired Mr. Diamond,
Jimmy Diamond. Oh, absolutely, he
lost $9 billion!
Fire him or put him in prison. Well, that's
your problem, not
mine. My problem is that banks
must manage
their boards
of directors and their executives according to
the long-term interests of their
clients, the bank, and the industry.
And if we take the case of GP Morgan, $9
billion in losses,
a chairman who receives $23
million... that's not...  Not consistent with
the general interest, so precisely, in the—
I'll use the term "
general interest"—within the
Trilateral Commission, broadly speaking, moreover, in
your
very specific grand schemes,
like the CFR, why not? And you were talking earlier about
representation of
all categories, yes, where are the young people?
Where are the young people? Where are the representatives?
I'm delighted by this question because
we are currently formulating a
proposal within the
Trilateral Commission to recruit people aged 30 to
45, because the others are still
older, and in order to
integrate them into our thinking. But it
takes time because you went—
you went to Russia—to
invite people, representatives—
I was going to say—of popular wisdom.
I have the idea that comes to
mind—he's no longer here, he's no longer of this
world—but representatives of this type—did we
take a secular Abbé Pierre
within?
Yes, we take people who have a way of
thinking that is not
altered or by  Neither money nor
political position will solve everything. We have people who
are wise, I agree,
because I
would like to say something similar to what I said: the enemy
of solutions is, let's
say, the bonus. And we saw that well
in the case of Mr.
Diamond, who is at the very top and
gives himself a very large bonus, which
allows everyone at the bottom to have
one too. I believe the solution,
when you say for example that the
20 central banks should
start to act, is true. I know that
central banks are often
independent of
political power, but I think the only
real solution is political. That is to
say, I must respond
to what you are saying: that enough
individuals in society become
aware of both the problems and
the solutions to elect politicians
who will then impose a solution. And
let's take an example of how this can be
done, how this can be done on the
margins, by not having politicians who
are sufficiently, at that moment,
willing and detached.  From the world of high
finance, to be able to impose these
decisions, since they know that if they
impose this type of
decision on the financial market, as
Mr. de Carmois said
earlier, if it doesn't go through directly, it will go around it,
and their next
term will be jeopardized.
I think that first, we need to raise
general awareness
among as many
people as possible. One day, a
major politician in a major country—
France, Italy, the United States, England,
Germany—must be elected on a
platform that centrally addresses these issues,
and that little by little, they will
impose it on the rest. This is what we call
the tipping point. There will come a time when things will
change, the turning point, and
these issues will spread
throughout society. This can only happen through
the awareness of individuals who
elect politicians who say, "Yes,
this issue is mine, I'm taking it on,
I'm adopting it, and I'm
imposing it." And I'm going to tell you something
that might surprise you...  He almost succeeded,
and that doesn't mean
I voted for him, it doesn't mean
I supported what he did.
Besides, we almost had that in France
with Nicolas Sarkozy, who, at the end of his
term, perfectly understood one
thing: the value of the
micro-tax on innovative markets. He
wanted to
impose it on that very issue. He was
very close to being the first
major politician willing to champion this
cause. That's right. It's a fact that's being
said. How do you create a movement?
Well, first you have to convince
economic journalists, you have to
convince newspapers in general,
and you have to hold
meetings with members of parliament. I
participated in some of these meetings. It must be
said that our members of parliament know
relatively little about
financial and economic issues and can
improve, but they are often curious, right?
And it's a long
educational process. So, we're talking about
journalists; perhaps that's why this isn't being
covered enough by the
mainstream media, and I'll take advantage of this
little reflection.  To tell me how it is that as soon as
10, just 10 personalities
gather in a hotel, it attracts a
crowd of paparazzi, while when you yourself
meet for the
Trilateral Commission, nobody talks about it anywhere.
We refer to it in comparison to the
Bilderberg meeting, which took place in
England, which had a huge number of paparazzi and
people at the doors, but
inside, we didn't have access to
what was being discussed. And we
remember Mr. Y. Calvi, in particular, a
few years ago, maybe two years ago,
who discovered what the
Bilderberg Group was on his own channel.
Your opinion on the newspaper? Yes, me, me, me,
if you want it, it's
a good question, but
I'm not going to answer in a way
that would be influenced by your
question. In other words, I don't think
that the Trilateral Commission, having been on its
executive committee,
should publicize itself or explain itself,
because that's not its purpose. Its purpose is
very specific: to  Taking
the issues that cause us friction with the United
States, China, and
Japan—monetary matters, freedom of
movement, the
quality of justice,
military effort—all these questions, and
discussing them privately, and
generating
other ideas that will influence
roughly 400 people worldwide—that's
our objective. Can we
make a suggestion? Yes, the suggestion
we would make is to make some
of your work
public so that the internet can also
reflect with you and you can
benefit from the
collaborative intelligence of the internet. I think that currently,
we believe
the strength of the internet is that it
connects
minds, and there are many, many
people online who
could perhaps help you. So
try to make your work a little more public,
have live streams
during your conferences, without making everything
public. There's a proverb in
intelligence that says if everyone
talks, nothing works, but if no one
talks, we die. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, we must
improve our communication, you're right.
The reality is that for the past
30 years we've changed
mindsets in the United States
compared to Europe, Russia, and China, and in
China regarding freedoms. The same is true, albeit temporarily,
in
Russia. We reinforced the trend
towards free trade, we built
numerous and often invisible bridges that
must be respected in collaboration between
Europe, Russia, the United
States, China, and Japan in the
scientific field. So we've done
significant, albeit invisible, work.
Let me say that I somewhat
corroborate what our
friends at Thinkervview are saying. I believe that
today we desperately need—
and I think it's internet users
and people everywhere
in the world—a high
moral authority in which they can
have confidence. Because there's a real
crisis of confidence at the same time as there's a
massive dissemination of knowledge. That is to
say, there are more and more
people who understand the problems and
who, obviously, being unable or
powerless to solve them, begin to
despair.  Many young people are
in this state, and so if there were
another moral authority, I understand
very well that for 30 years you have
influenced a small number of decision-makers,
but I believe that if it were possible, if
you could represent a
credible morality to a very, very
large number of people, that would be good too.
Yes, because I'm coming back to this
moral authority, as well as to the
influential people you were talking about earlier. In a way,
everyone is acting
a bit for their own benefit. Within
this circle of extremely
influential members, you rely on a kind
of balance of interests. Shouldn't
we, people outside these circles, also fear
a convergence of interests
among the decision-makers that would
push us towards something that wouldn't
necessarily be in the direction of the
common good? There won't be a
balance of interests; there will be a
balance of debates. That is to say,
we will find Americans who
will be very opposed to certain
policies.  In Africa, or elsewhere,
Japanese people who don't want to liberalize
their
internal trade will find
all these opinions expressed. And because they will be
expressed forcefully, let's
take the liberalization of trade in
Japan by Americans and
other Japanese. The Japanese leaders will
return home and say, "Listen, we
must take this into consideration," and
they will contribute to moving things forward, towards something
more.  of democracy because it's
the central theme, so
more freedom, more people
participating in decisions, more
consideration for the common good.
So, do we truly understand at
all times what the common good is? There's
room for improvement, and we're
trying. We bring in people who have
opposing views, who have
opposing views among themselves, so we can have a good
discussion. And we remain, I think,
modest, meaning that we
debate, we have specialists, and then
everyone goes back to their country trying to
make progress. Okay, so it's not
unrealistic to imagine
seeing groups like yours
push for new
solutions in
the energy transition that is necessary
today, new solutions that
could jeopardize lobbies worth
billions—I'm thinking of the oil industry. Do
you reach the point of a head-on clash
with the lobbies? Does
the Trilateral Commission, through
its recommendations, reach a point of
head-on clash? Do we reach a point where...  On
topics like energy, we have two opposing
viewpoints expressed at a meeting of
150 people. What are
they? The degree of investment
that should be supported by states
in new energy sources... There's
a view from a major
European country that has invested tens of
billions
and obtained no results: Magne.
And then you have other countries,
like ours, that believe that
a
nuclear industry, very demanding in terms of
safety, is something that must be
preserved. Meanwhile, we have views
completely opposed to France,
expressed at the Trilateral Commission. Jean-
Manuel, you were a wealth manager
for very large fortunes. Did
your clients
simply ask for returns, or was there a
real ethical dimension to
the investment? For example, did
you allocate a portion of your
portfolio to new projects or
things like that? It's very specific
to the period when I did this job.
Our goal was to
financially support
competent entrepreneurs in
interesting fields. That is to say, from this
point of view...  From that perspective, in high-
margin businesses, and so the whole exercise I did
during the 15 or 16 years I was in
this business was to find
people who were
good at what they did and to find
ways, with various clients, to
allow them to grow. From that point of view, there was
an obvious objective: in
some cases, we helped create a massive number
of jobs since we put capital
in the hands of people who started with 12 and
reached 7,000. That's not bad, but I'm not
saying that was the only goal. The goal
was to find ways to grow in the long, medium, and
short
term. I want to tell you that the
long term is a failed speculation that
becomes an investment, but that wasn't the idea.
The idea was to
find people all over the world and in
different industries who
were very good at what they did and
give them access to the
capital necessary for their growth. It worked well.
One question: did
Education is an
investment with good
margins. Listen, I don't know, to tell you the truth,
I'm not sure that education is
an area that is 100% and
solely the responsibility of
private companies. I believe it necessarily involves
the State as well. But generally speaking,
education is the investment
with the best margins because it is
through education and knowledge that
we create wealth, growth,
democracy, and employment. So
without education, there is nothing. It's a
long-term investment, yes, but it
all depends on who's doing it. Is it
the State or is it
private companies? Okay,
good question,
Hervé. I see you smiling, but yes, I'm
smiling because I think that when
clients entrust me with
money, I think long-term. I've
always thought long-term. So it's a
failed investment? No, we chose
15 years ago to invest in
SMEs. One SME 15 years ago, a new
SME every
year. We've created 1,000
jobs, and we  It was done according to rules
that go against the market, not a
government loan, not a bank loan.
Individuals joined the fund
for 15 to 20 years, and it worked. It worked
because we had a
leader who knew how to choose where to
invest, that's all. So,
I'll continue, yes, well,
I think that people who
entrust you with their money have what I
call a propensity for risk, and you
have to take that into account. But if they're
ready to take risks, they were
ready to take them with us, and well, we
took them.
We made money for 15
years, we didn't lose a company, and
we focused on the fact that we did
n't have money from banks and no
money from the government. What's
interesting about risk is that what
you're saying proves that often what
people think is extremely risky isn't so much,
and what they think isn't risky is extremely risky.
I'll
give you a simple example: if...  In 2007, you
decided to buy a basket of the
world's best-performing stocks, the C-
listed ones from the CAC 40, and at the same time
invest some money in
supporting a small or medium-sized enterprise (SME) in the digital sector,
for example. You might think, "
My CAC 40 basket isn't risky, my
SME basket is risky." It's the
opposite: the P-listed basket, considered risk-free
according to investment principles, loses
80% in two years, while the other one
succeeds. So it's really
this assessment of risk that's so
important. Also, because
central banks injected enormous amounts
of liquidity, and some people
took positions in 2009
in banking stocks, anticipating
that governments wouldn't let
the banks fail, they made huge
profits. I won't name the
manager of an American fund who
made $7.9 billion between 2009 and
2011. It's also a way of interpreting things. If you
have a slightly distorted view of the
financial system, you can make a lot of money.
I don't think there's anything
perverse about being bearish
when the market is falling. No, it's not about
being bearish, it's about
placing put options
on the downside to bet that it will
fall. It's an
investor psychology that can be
respectable or not, it's not for
N to judge. However, betting
that states won't abandon their
banks and speculating on that
can be debatable. We're not going to go back over that,
it deserves another interview.
We're going to ask you one last question: does
my colleague have any other
questions? Uh, I would have liked to have
a few words from you on the
transatlantic market, the
transatlantic market, and more specifically
the fact that very large companies—we're
obviously thinking of Monsanto—could
potentially sue a
country tomorrow, which is
[Music]
totally possible right now, but this
simple thought is making my brain a little uneasy.
I would have liked to know what
you
thought about it.  The same scale, in fact,
the transatlantic market includes
companies, some of which have revenues
equal to a
significant percentage of certain European states. That's
a fact. They create
jobs, they create wealth,
they
are under scrutiny from
various American and European authorities, and overall,
they behave fairly well.
So, are there
excesses? Yes,
recently I've seen excesses in
the chemical and
medical sectors. But when you look at the
top 300
companies
worldwide, I would say that my criticism isn't
about what they do, but what they don't do. That is to
say, there are
several trillion
dollars that aren't invested by these
companies, that sit on their balance sheets and
certainly contribute to global liquidity,
but we would prefer that they
invest it to create wealth
and jobs, and they don't.
And the real question is
why? And the answer
is a lack of vision, a lack of
visibility. No, I don't think so. I think that...
When I know of companies with
30-50 billion in liquidity that don't
internally, through their
research centers, through all the
elements, the proposals from their
merchants, generate enough
new ideas that need to be
implemented, and
so we never blame them, but there's a
problem with general management. Two
last questions: we always end
our
interviews with recommendations,
advice. Jean-Manuel Rosant, a piece of advice
for the internet users watching us:
choose the topic. So, if we
stay on this topic, I'll divide it in two. We've
talked about this on other occasions. I
think young people
absolutely must understand the internet. It's not
today's topic at all, but there are very, very
important issues,
particularly regarding privacy on the
internet today, and ideally, they should
know as much as possible,
especially learning to code. That would
allow them to understand exactly what's
happening in the internet world. But on the other hand,
we're in France here, and
I think we're very, very, very influenced
by the French mindset, by
French problems, by everything that  It happened here,
I think, that people in
France, obviously, when we talk about
global growth, when we say how fast it's going to go,
and when I tell you that
innovation worldwide is
changing the world and we're heading towards very, very
significant growth in
the coming years, people
tell us, "You're crazy, what are you talking about?"
So I say to the young people listening to us,
it's true, it's possible, we have to
bring it back to France, we have to do it
in France too, but we're in a
period of exceptional opportunity
in the
world, and we have to see as much as possible
how other countries are
succeeding, why the United
States is doing so well now,
and I'm going to
give you part of the
answer: in the
United States, last year there were
1,003 immigrants who came, of which
800,000, if you will, came from
families where
the man had left and
then the woman and children,
family reunification, and then a few
hundred thousand came for
political reasons, but there were
140,000 skilled men and women from all over the
world, you're talking about the
United States, you're talking about the... it's
not the green card, it's the
paperwork to be able to attract talent
abroad, absolutely, completely,
and 140,000, huh?
During this
period, we lost 30,000
skilled French people, that is to say, compared to
our population, 65 against
320. We lost as many
skilled men and women as the Americans
gained in skilled men and women,
and so I say that we must be extremely vigilant about not
losing our
best people. In
Belgium, there were 3,000 French people in the
wealthy commune; there were 11,000 five
years ago; there are 11,000 today; there are
tens of thousands. There are
450,000 French people in Great Britain,
tens of thousands in Switzerland, and we
lost some of the most dynamic.
We lost between 5 and 10% of the
most dynamic French people.  Dynamics for
foreigners, and we must
monitor and
avoid that. I was going to simply ask,
why do they leave? Why do
they leave? I imagine it's for
financial reasons, right? Yes, it's not simply that. It's the
fact that
since
1685, well,
I come from a
Protestant family, so the
elites who make money and create
wealth are frowned upon. That was the
case in 1685, it was the case at the end of
18. Never any smoke and mirrors, yes, yes, the
population has this critical spirit towards
the rich. It's perhaps a lack
of transparency, perhaps envy,
perhaps also a reality for
some. When, when, when, I don't believe,
how, I don't believe, but I'll
give you my version of things.
We saw some families speculating
during the
Second World War. That
left its mark on some people,
so respecting people who
invest and make money
is true.  In France, we
tend not to respect them very much, which
I think is a mistake because we
need leaders, we need
brilliant minds, people
who take risks, but we
also need to respect those who have experienced
or witnessed certain wrongdoings.
Wealth should
be virtuous, and what would help it
most to be virtuous is for it to be
transparent and acknowledged. In
France, we have a very, very big
cultural problem, which is this: France is
the land of equality—equality,
liberty, fraternity—but in reality, in France,
we are free to do
everything except be different. We must be
equal; equality is mandatory. In
Anglo-Saxon countries, difference is
embraced. That is to say, the goal of
society is to allow everyone to
embrace their difference. So in France,
when we have a difference, we are forced
to keep it hidden. And
when our difference isn't
physical, it isn't fashion-related, it is
n't a headscarf, a turban, or anything like that...
Laakipa, but it's about money, and
well, we hide it. That's the problem with
France. It's entirely that in a world that is
primarily liberal, primarily
Anglo-Saxon, primarily focused on the
possibility for individuals to have
access to their differences, France
cannot promote the right to be different.
We saw it in a very simple way:
we had a president elected in 2007
saying, "I'm going to make a break." We
understand what this
break means: "I'm going to
force you to excel, I'm going to
force you to function, it's going to be
mandatory." So we tell him, "Okay, it's
not nice, but we'll let you try." It doesn't work.
And so we have a
president who is then elected saying, "
I'm going to be normal," that is to say, "
I'm not going to be different." Both
are excessive. The final word
is confidence in the future of
France, right? Because we have 65
million inhabitants, we have a
significant growth rate, we fortunately have a
very significant emigration rate, a significant
demographic growth, yes, a
significant demographic growth that we  We have people coming from all over
Europe and
North Africa who want to succeed, and
these elements will shake up
French society so that it moves
forward. I have complete
confidence that in the
next two or three decades, they will
renew France's elites
in a way that will benefit the
entire country. Gentlemen,
thank
you. What is truly
intolerable is
mass surveillance, as Eric Fillol said. It's
the presumption of guilt. It's
massive violations of our
individual freedoms that cannot, under
any circumstances, respect the principle of
proportionality because we have finally
caught up with the Americans.
And then we will be able to show the NSA
that we can do it too, and we can do it. We are good, we
are very good at
surveillance. The problem
is for democracy, but the
reality of the risk is camouflaged at all
levels. Banks have
very significant internal losses that they don't
show. Central banks do
n't demand transparency.
tasked with conducting audits in
even less and the general management
are silent in all languages
[Music]